[Music]
[Applause]
it's time to babble the [__] on
it's hollywood babylon
with your hosts kevin smith and ralph
garman
[Music]
oh my god it is [__] saturday night
and burbank is done totally how do i
start the show oh for [__] sake but
it's saturday
holy [__] it's saturday night in burbank
[__] i forget
the burbank is throwing me hold on let
me [__] all right holy [__] it's
saturday night in hollywood let's babble
the [__] on i'm kevin smith i'm ralph
garcia
yeah we'll fix that in post don't worry
about it
um holy [__] man how are you happy new
year happy well
belated but yeah well it's our first
show of 2022. you're absolutely right
thank you so much welcome to the new
year kids
all right good night everybody yeah
omicron's been defeated yeah
kovid's been defeated racism has been
defeated it's a brand new world yeah
2022 is everything we all hoped it was
tom brady sitting his ass down it's all
good
is that a sports ball thing that's the
sports ball thing yeah what happened
fill me in uh tom brady who plays
football kevin he's a quarterback he
throws the ball i'm familiar with his
work yes
uh statement came out today saying he
was stop he was quitting 44 years old
he's retiring from the game oh is that
right and then his father came out and
said no he's not
you're like dad shut up you're
embarrassing me
so we don't know whether he is or not
why does he think he's retiring i choose
to believe cause he's 44 years old he
doesn't get hit by large black men
anymore i'm guessing
sounds so [__] hot when you describe
it like that is that what [__]
football i know i wouldn't quit i'd stay
in there but
to each his own i guess football sounds
like a category on pornhub i'm in all
the time
how you doing i've seen you for a minute
let me tell you something my friend i'm
old uh i'll tell you why i'm as old as
me
that's true you're older yes i've been
uh
after i ha i mean i don't want to bum
anybody out but by the end of the
december
um the dog our dog marty the rescuer
sorry convalescing uh you know for a
good four [__] months when we got
back from clerks three was just taking
care of marty i spent an inordinate
amount of time staring at a dog's
[__] because
if she couldn't get up to [__] so it's
like if the tail moved slightly
it was like that scene in jaws where the
line click click clicks and quint like
puts himself into the [__] chair
because i'd rush over there and put a
[__] pad under her because it would
come out and [__] she just couldn't move
so there's four months of that and in
the end it was really [__] bad and
she eventually left us and it was
heartbreaking enough that i ate my
[__] grief for like a good month and
i got very big so
20 days ago
i started uh hiking running canyon again
and that's your thing uh and i did day
20 today man and i thank you
but thank you
love being a celebrity they cheer you
for like you walked
[Applause]
sp
i saw a guy not to interrupt your story
yeah but you were documenting your daily
hike i saw a guy
on social media responded to you i know
you saw this or not but he said well i
wish i had your money so i could get in
shape
i was like the dude is walking yeah
that's all he's doing can you can you
afford to walk sir i'm assuming you can
it's not like the jetsons ramp where you
walk astray
or something like that just kidding
outside your house what what what i do
have what a lot of people don't have is
time
because that walk from door to door is
four miles and it's like an at 90
minutes of the day so some people are
like i ain't got [__] five minutes to
jerk off let alone 90 minutes to walk so
that's where it's a real [__] luxury
and being home for all month like you
know [__] omicron sucked but for me
it was great for my schedule because i
got to stay home and just hike runyon
without having to leave or anything like
that so right 20 days unbroken i'm on
day three of a fast i just passed 74
hours so i'm feeling
hungry
i can imagine no oddly enough i'm not
feeling hungry at all i'm feeling
energetic so if i seem like weird
tonight it's because i'm like high and
empty at the same time
great combination this should be a great
show then you guys are in for a treat i
figured out a [__] yeah i figured out i
got a plantars
physicist plant plantar fasciitis do you
know what that is i do i had it once
myself
how did you [__] get it very painful
yeah well yeah it sucks it's in your
foot from like i don't know what it's
from walking i guess yeah um and and i
had to get insoles in my [__] shoe
um i had to get special like [__]
sock you wear and i i feel so
like i'm one shower chair away from
being my mom and and i put that on
twitter where i was like i'm gonna need
a shower chair next and you would be
shocked
by the amount of young people who are
like don't discount the shower chair
it's very cool [__] are like i sit on
the shower chair and get stoned in my
shower while i shower and suddenly i was
like what a revelation what a great idea
i'm gonna [__] start sitting in the
shower you know normally i don't sit
anywhere except [__] here because i
wanted my gut to be like hello jabba so
like i don't even sit in the [__]
shower and we do have like a bench in
the shower so i could totally sit there
and [__] smoke weed and still take a
shower how [__] decadent would that
be
you know what i'm saying add that to my
90 minutes of walking time you know
um but the other thing i've been doing a
lot which is so [__] strange leron
our dp
on clerks three um when we were making
the flick
i talked about liking hummus and [__]
cause i was like i'm trying to find the
right hummus in new jersey and he's like
oh i'm making some bummers and i was
like yeah [__] right and he was like
it's it's [__] ground beans bro it's
not like you know [__] the [__]
kfc secret recipe he's like i'll bring
you some hummus he brought me some
[__] hummus man some homemade hummus
that he made himself by hand and [__]
and mind you i treated him good so i
didn't have to worry about the hummus or
anything like that all right
um or you treat him too good and you had
to worry about it either way either way
i don't give a [__] if he came all over
the hummus because it was [__]
amazing it was the best hummus ever had
secret sauce right there when he gets
very much when he tahini indeed
the uh he
he was out in uh to shoot with us uh did
we talk about this last time you and the
movie my little cameo ralph being in
clerks three so uh uh leron was out here
yes [__] hey thank you fisto in
clerkship um
so he was out here and he was like hey
man we got half a day before i got to do
some [__] why don't i teach you how to
make hummus and i was like oh master
teach me
he came to the kitchen taught me how to
comment she will make [__] yeah man oh
my god i became the yoda of hummus um
i'm more the luke of hummus
yeah totally but now
when i left i was about a learner now i
am the master because i've been making
hummus like [__] crazy right so i
make batches the wife the kid are super
impressed like the kid especially
because kids like oh my god this is the
best i'm like right and i was like
you're not just saying that because of
your father she's like i've never
[__] treated you any better than
anybody just because you're [__]
kevin smith and i was like back off bro
[__] if anything it was the opposite
she'd be harder than you truly man she
kept the bar real [__] high but she
that hummus man she's like finally
you've made the best thing you've ever
made since clerks that's what she said
so
so i go this is this is the point of the
story i i go to this uh israeli grocery
store to get the good tahiti because you
know [__] you know everyone else you
know i like whole foods don't get me
wrong but they got that name brand
tahini and [__] you got to go deep son
sure yeah you got to go deep in to get
that black market tahini not black
markings meet a guy in a van behind a uh
a parking lot
or an israeli grocery store
which i've been going to so much that
the [__]
clerk
recognized me
and i thought he recognized me because
oh this is this is the tahini boy he cut
boy this is the tahini old man
who comes in and [__] buys tahini
every three days and like what's he
doing with all that tahini and [__] i
make a lot of hummus so i go and i'm
picking up this tahini and this [__]
slayed me man he goes um
for the guy who made that dogma movie
about catholics you sure seem to spend a
lot of time in this store
you think you're converting that's what
i [__] that's the next thing he goes
he goes you thinking about conversion
i said you know what man i am thinking
about joining the tribe
and he goes why for a wife and i was
like no for a hummus [__]
cause you people got this [__] down to a
science man and he was just like just
because we serve you doesn't mean we
like you and i was like oh my god i
found the one israeli [__] clerks fan
in the world
didn't give me any money off of my order
but whatever
like
celebrity only goes so far right so i'm
gonna make you some hummus you eat
hummus i do i know you're like hooked up
with a cook a real cooking [__] i could
only make one dish but
i might out homicide i'm all about the
hummus yeah
be a homosexual with me
shalom
uh what have you been up to uh just
working pretty much you know i do a
little thing called the ralph report
which is uh
why thank you
thanks for remembering
um so that keeps me busy five days a
week and then once a month we come by
here to flappers and do our thing
starting off at once a month we may add
more depending on whether you know we're
doing a show next month virus kills us
or not yeah really a virus depending
yeah we got another one coming up in
february
what day uh the 26th i believe that is
my anniversary show february 26 is four
makes four years ago that i had the
massive heart attack and almost [__]
die oh
yes [__] so i don't wanna celebrate
that there i don't wanna betty white
this [__] but that's what's gonna happen
we're going to get that date man so buy
your tickets now everyone's like i
bought tickets and he [__] dropped
dead two days before the show yeah
really but yeah that's the way we're
gonna get a refund if that happens by
the way don't worry about it [__] you
you keep doing the show no no i couldn't
no you do both you do impressions do me
the amazing memorial show like what a
weird eulogy he [__] did heal hauser
and kevin smith talking to each other he
put the head on he took the head
off on
february 26th february 26th our tickets
on sale flappers tickets are on sale now
the anniversary show kids celebrating
the fact that god willing i'm still
alive on that day because four years ago
i was on a stage performing oh that was
between shows shooting the showtime
special we were supposed to uh shoot two
two shows and we did the seven o'clock
show and i was like it was two hours and
the director was just like we cut the
whole thing from that from the from that
show and i was like well you know
everyone's waiting for the second show
and that's when i started feeling
[__] weird and [__] and the rest i've
talked about many [__] times but that
was four years ago to be sitting up here
performing [__] making people laugh
making you laugh making me laugh and
[__] four years to the day of when that
[__] like my heart literally attacked me
and i was like [__] you
the only fight i've ever gotten into my
life yeah
with my own body go figure um so yes
that will be the anniversary show that's
how we'll [__] market it all right
we're still alive we're just gonna do
one show that night though just in case
yes
that's the key yes get in get out before
it all goes south that'll be good that'd
be a nice way to i was wondering what i
was gonna do for that day but there it
is we'll be here [__] night did did
you want me to bring this note out for
yourself yes
absolutely gabs told me about this
before i'm gonna ask the folks to engage
uh with us and a special little gift for
a couple kids who
had some special news uh tim and
ashley
uh they uh a couple years ago we were
doing the jay and sam bob road show tour
right uh they were uh with child they
were pregnant
and uh
like do you know what with child means
yes i do i'm pretty sure
um so they uh unfortunately lost the
baby yeah
and uh they were very sad they were both
looking forward to going to the show uh
she was like please you go to the show
without he went to the show i met him we
took pictures and stuff like that uh in
any event they just found out
that they're having a baby
which is awesome so
i said to gabs we would shoot a little
video uh and and so i know it's painting
ass but at least give you the
opportunity to say like ben affleck i
have been directed by kevin smith yeah
dot dot dot poorly um the idea here is
uh we're gonna start on let's see
how do i do this
you don't know how to direct anymore is
that what you're saying
i wanna help me make movies
well i want to do me and then i was like
i want to give it landscape mode as well
but i want to start on me but i can't
flip it it'll stop recording i'm having
cheese my internal monologue is outside
here
i'm going to make it work i'm going to
start on you okay what am i gonna do
you're gonna say
[__] i forgot to set the bit up you say
uh
uh see fasting and pot may not be the
best way to go that's all i'm saying
it's true i'm high and malnourished um
high and weak
you're going to go down mid shell
so horrible high and weak that's how i
keep them
um okay
it's going to start uh on
shows an hour kevin just letting you
know just a reminder
remember this is a good thank you so
much [__] ladies and gentlemen dr josh
roush
[Applause]
all right it's gonna start on us and
then i'm gonna turn and show the crowd
and so we're gonna say uh tim and ashley
we just wanted to congratulate you
um on uh
you know
on
getting pregnant
just follow my [__] lead and then you
add your two cents but then
you when you end it you when you're done
talking
you say and i think the audience will
agree with me here
and then i'm gonna turn the camera on
the audience and you all are gonna go
tim [__] ashley
see it was worth the [__] weight jobs
roush
doctor my ass all right here we go it
was a longer hike to get to that story
than it was to get up runyon canyon
you're a [__] prick man all right
here we go
oh i look thinner all right here we go
because you're not eating
for three days that's the key what is
the key all right here we go okay
tim and ashley yeah timmy
hey tim and ashley's meet kevin smith
and me ralph garman and we just wanted
to congratulate you on uh have i'm being
pregnant man having a kid is [__]
nuts and wonderful isn't it wrong it's
so nuts and so wonderful congratulations
to wishing you all the best
and i think
cut what the [__]
maybe you are going to say something you
could have driven a truck through that
pause i thought you were gonna say
something else like you usually do
but maybe you're gonna start talking
about elvis or something i thought maybe
we had an opening there
here we go take two all right keep it
[__] tight and remember to throw to
them
you have a question
yeah let me tell you something my friend
that is total matt damon right there
that is a performer who wants to know
exactly what i'm looking for i
appreciate that man
all right so here let's [__] let's
read good point [__]
you want to you know they say the first
straighten things out for him
next generation of performers could be
a-okay there's proof right there
all right so here's how we'll go ralph
will say whatever his setup like and
then i think the audience will agree
with me when we say
wow is that wait you're going to add
that when we say part yeah
because i would have as soon as i would
have been like i would have false
started because i was expecting you to
say what i [__] asked you to say
which is i think the audience michael
bay right there
matt damon michael bay
i think the audience would agree with me
that here there oh
there and there and then uh there where
here here here what does that even mean
there here it's a line from mall rats
bro and i can't remember if it's here
there
oh my doctor [__] suits just say here
so i think the audience would agree with
me here and then on here i spin the
camera uh-huh [__] like michael bay
yeah
and then a giant robot crash cg on the
ceiling
and then we go this way as i'm shooting
this way
we go
just you so what's your name
what's your name future matt damon
louis
give it up for louie everybody he's
listening
he's not just listening he's hearing
all right louis so you're gonna be the
lone voice in this rehearsal he's in
rehearsal or the whole thing rehearsal
of just that one part okay but everyone
else is gonna join with him when we
shoot this when we shoot yeah okay
you know just louie
i would like to not participate if
that's okay hold on hold on
[__] we're doing that
we're doing two takes one is everybody
and then the second is hauntingly just
louie
as i pan across and when i pan across no
[__] smile yeah
you're all horrified by louis yes i want
you to have the [__] most serious fa
even grim like
give us your game face oh this is
awesome in fact
should we all look at lulu we have
another [__]
camera man now we're inside the [__]
actor's studio
i should have blue cards up here
this is the best all right here we go
when you shot tim and ashley
kevin smith i remember you saying to one
particular audience member
louie
here we go
tim and ashley
there was a lot of conversation man
all right
hey tim and ashley it's me kevin smith
and it's me ralph garman and we would
just want to congratulate
yeah who was that one on that was me all
right i'll take that one okay but i'm
the director and an actor so cut me some
slack okay here we go
hey
tim and ashley
just wanted to make sure man here we go
hey tim and ashley it's me kevin smith
hey and it's me ralph garman
and we just wanted to congratulate you
guys on getting pregnant ain't that
right ralph it is congratulations and i
think the audience would agree with me
here
congratulations
all the best
all right you didn't listen take one
was supposed to be everybody but that
was [__] awesome
that was so haunting was that even louie
who said it was [__]
it wasn't louie
who's so ben affleck right there
to jump in and steal louise exactly you
all about eve that [__] well done
wow um all right this time everybody
goes
oh for [__] sake louie you're a pain
in the ass
louie don't listen to him don't be
intimidated by this [__]
bully
we're going when he says i think the
audience would agree with me there i
turn the camera and then you go
tim [__] ashley and that's what i'm
doing with the camera you don't have to
do this i'm doing that
i'm just showing you what the camera's
gonna do so i won't do that so nobody
gets confused but everybody's gonna say
it this time literally everybody even
the [__] staff and [__]
bring the staff out
all right here we go
remember
i remember what that everybody does at
this time tim and ashley tim thank you
timon
i mean i'm not for nothing but runyon's
paying off yeah you look thin okay you
look thin
hey tim and ashley it's me kevin smith
and it's me ralph garner and we just
wanted to congratulate you did we
what the [__]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're going to stroke out in the middle
of the tape
right here
why is my face looping
[__] i hope i'm having a stroke
and [__]
fast everybody here face arm something
time okay
speech thank you
here we go
we're doing a little bit of this
[Laughter]
tip and actually i'm very happy for you
both
with the babies and things and
here we go yes stop it all right
hey tim and ashley it's me kevin smith
and me ralph garman and we just wanted
to congratulate you on getting pregnant
man well done isn't that great ralph
we're wishing you all the best and i
think the audience would agree with me
here
let me see if i got it all
hold on it looks like i got everything
but the audience
oh my god it goes tim and i could tell
oh my god one more take that was perfect
that was perfect one more like that
why am i putting this down i don't know
here we go
[__]
hey tim and ashley it's me kevin smith
and ralph garman and we just wanted to
congratulate you with all our hearts on
getting pregnant isn't that great ralph
wishing you guys all the best and i
think the audience would agree with me
here
[Applause]
there we go
that is more takes than anything i did
on clerk's three yeah
unbelievable
well that's all the time we have for
tonight folks so thanks for coming by
[Applause]
oh that was worth it just for you to
cosby out
there's so few opportunities
pop out again that was pretty amazing
all right thank you everybody
now it's time for us to say to some
folks hello there in the audience folks
who come particularly long distances are
celebrating special occasions with us
tonight it's a segment we call the shout
outs
it's a shout out
we're kevin and round so get your [__]
out
[Music]
get your cocktails i'm sure that mic has
been set at times i'm sure it has
ray glover and heather are you guys here
ray and heather
what
no
louie
uh my fiance will be attending flappers
on 129. oh i guess maybe things didn't
work out for him
[Laughter]
at least that's what i'm hoping because
if you're gonna send a [__] email
show up to the [__] show that's all i
said
heather smarten them [__] dark yes
uh
daniel jenny joey and tanya yeah yeah
that's how you do it they're over by
louis is chris here because he said
chris may be coming he may not
[__] chris
never like those other two [__] we
don't like that's right
dana writes attending hollywood babylon
with my girlfriend jenny cousin joey his
wife tanya we came from san diego the
holy holy [__] thank you so much that's
like two hours away yeah that's
it's not worth the trip
but thank you
uh we'll be here for the first cove
excuse me first coven first hbo since
covet started my girlfriend will be
breaking her hbo cherry tonight well
she's lucky
what it's just a joke everyone got real
serious i think it was i think i don't
know if a busting a cherry is like a
thing anymore yeah i think people are
like what the f what kind of animal are
you
it's one of those terms that just went
well let me tell you
i was wondering if the germans can
explain to her what she could expect
tonight from the show
hopefully lots of anal and [__] jokes
how dare you sir um
what's her name um
jenny thank you so much jenny the
germans are going to explain to jenny
what to expect for tonight
[Music]
yeah yeah we are not laziest nine
although it's very on brand in today's
america yes we'd have a lot of company
if we were but we're not so much in no
more anymore no no we just have many
confederate flags yeah yes we do let's
go brandon
so anyway
johnny welcome to the show we're coming
in yes
this is a show where we pretend we are
german yeah it's very fun and then we'll
make an entire movie before the show
gets started it's very lengthy but
entertaining wasn't that satisfying
jenny
nothing from her nothing
nine nine response
i am no lenny riefenstahl
deep cut thank you
[Applause]
yes
jenny just walked out yeah she did
is jenny a girlfriend
oh my god
you're gonna be like the first [__]
people man you're like
come to the show
with her going like we should really
separate yeah
we should you really think that was
funny
we should see other podcasts
[Laughter]
derek stokes are you here derek stokes
do that's how you do it where are you
derek is stoked um
listening to your show for a long time
finally had a chance to see your show
because of my amazing girlfriend cat is
she with you is cat there hi cat home
here
she has no idea what's ahead of her this
evening well no one knows what the show
is like apparently she just heard from
the germans and she's like jesus yeah
i'm in trouble there's another hour of
this [__]
it would explain it would be amazing if
you could have edwin explain what's in
store for her
tonight edwin is her favorite voice that
i do which i stole from you
oh that's sweet derek that's nice you'll
be hearing from my lawyers
oh my goodness yes welcome to the show i
hope you have a good time tonight it's
crazy i don't know if you heard but
ashley's having a baby
we're all very excited don't you know
it's going to be crazy we do lots of
things we do silly things you can enjoy
yourself but drink heavily it helps
there you go derrick and cat
[Music]
jeff and christina
i like that enthusiasm you know
christine it was like shut the [__] up
huge fan of you both writes jeff gonna
be at the show on saturday is wondering
if david bowie could wish my best friend
in the whole wide world christina a
happy birthday i just want her to know i
love her and support her with all my
heart thank you jeff and christina oh
that's very sweet and you were gonna get
so [__]
tonight i think they're just friends are
you guys just friends
yeah
i didn't mean with each other i
i just predicted you'll both get [__]
tonight a
big room full of opportunities here
david bowie wishing christina happy
birthday of course we can do that a
little music josh
happy birthday to christina
happy birthday to
[Music]
it's christina birthday christina
and jeff wants it to be happy
happy birthday to christina
you and jeff our only best friends
you won't be [__] tonight
no matter what kevin says
happy birthday to christina now come
on stop it
stop it
i forgot that i was part of that bit and
i started shooting you i i heard i heard
the camera drop i figured he just
figured something out
i was like he's so enjoyable
speaking of david bowie this is going to
be interesting uh daryl hefferman are
you here darryl
he's the tina [__] ashley guy
tim tim and ashley oh
yeah tina [__] eventually
i want to go to the show he's seeing
yeah me too much hotter
uh
dow writes this will be the first date
night for my wife maya and i since we've
been pandemics since the pandemic i was
like you guys have been married and
you're just dead you've never never been
on a date you're supposed to do it the
other way oh since the pandemic started
out with no kids i'm excited and nervous
are they right
uh we see you're very masked up yes
smart yes you want to i wanted to wear
one and ralph shamed me out of wearing
one i did because we need to put on a
brave face for the for the audience yeah
he was like [__] your face diaper and he
ripped it off that's right
and he waved confederate flag at me
let's go brandon
uh
in celebration of braving the public
rights daryl yes i think i'd love to
hear david bowie
and mick jaggers dancing in the street
but done as david bowie and bane can we
do that as a as oh my god i haven't sang
this song in a long time but i yeah
[__] i'm game forever yo yeah fresh
iced tea yeah thank you fresh thank you
it's time to do it man so i'll be bowie
and instead of mick jagger you'll be
bane how about that
story of my life you with me i said
story of my life all right it's a
dynamic duet is what it is dynamic
all right give me the sheet all right
here's your lyrics
here's my lyrics no preparation went
into this at all
and then it ends at the end of the sheet
yes
okay
it's just a little snippet okay of the
sh of the song this and this i'm all the
yellow
yes kevin
highlighted all of your things
let me can i ever can i warm up
feel free you got to warm up you did
bowie right before this
i don't want to make it unfair between
the two of us absolutely so go ahead
what a lovely singing voice
are you warm yes oh okay
don't strain yourself i was trying to do
what tom hardy did i went to a place man
i was trying to be bane not just [__]
play bane and [__]
people deserve more than all right lady
gaga i don't need to hear about your
process
i'm ready to say i lived as bain for a
year and a half
is that what she's saying about the
gucci picture yeah [__] shut up
she's saying she inhabited that guy yes
she had to live as her for a year
i mean it's a it's a wonderful movie and
she's great in it but like it's a real
spaghetti sauce accent yeah it's real
like you know five-year-olds going hey
what are you doing
yes what's the matter for you gucci
oh
gotta know no respect shut up in your
face
oh the little monster's gonna come after
us yeah i know it'd be canceled all
right bowie and bane dancing in the
streets have a little music there josh
[Music]
boy
intro two times
are you ready for a brand new beating
summer's here and the time is right for
dancing in the street they're dancing in
chicago
down to new orleans
in new york city and in gotham all we
need is music
dancing in the street
it doesn't matter what you wear
even a giant fur coat
so come on every guy
grab a girl
everywhere
around the world
[Music]
across the nation a chance for folks to
defeat
be laughing and singing and music
swinging
dancing in the street
all right there we go that wasn't too
embarrassing
i ran out of lyrics yes we did just in
time
we also get emails from all around the
world josh
[Music]
featuring kevin's reactions that's right
uh mike
funigiello
hey mike fenugiello hey you know lady
gaga with the things she does
oh my god you should be nominated for an
oscar thank you so much
from wilmington north carolina long time
listener first time emailer love the
show glad you both are babbling again i
wanted to hear what kevin's thought was
behind this amazon author description
thanks for all the free funny and keep
babbling on if you go to amazon and you
go to order a book yeah let's say and
then it's by a particular author you can
click on that author and get his bio
and that's what mike did and this is the
bio that came up and he wanted to know a
little bit more about it so let's take a
picture
for that from amazon
kevin writes i am a former north ireland
police officer who has spent the last
few years in the middle east
my book river friends was inspired by a
walk along the beautiful river tweed in
the scottish borders when visiting my
daughter and granddaughter who live in
the area i hope this will be the first
series of books about the river friends
and their many different adventures
writing children's book is but a real
departure from my background and
experience but it is such a privilege to
be able to reach young inquiring minds
kevin smith
and
wrote it while i was stoned
i've been fasting so long i feel like a
former north ireland police officer
there was one put it back up there dr
josh roush there was one line that makes
it he says
writing children's books is a real
departure from my background and
experience wink wink clerks oh well i
see
but it is such a privilege to be able to
reach young inquiring mind that part i
don't know what that's about yeah clerks
three wink winks
yes
uh people ems all the time with funny
names of their towns towns that are just
[__] up we never bothered really to
name this segment so we just call up
your town's got a [__] up name
[Music]
brad from dubbo australia writes in he
said australia has some of the most
[__] up places you'd ever want to see
i thought you might like this one now
here's the thing about this town's name
it's not [__] up so much as it is a
brag in my opinion can we see this name
of this town in australia
no [__]
welcome to iron knob
they're just bragging at that point i
heard my mother call my father that once
in the night when i was a child woken up
by oh iron knob i was like iron man it
wasn't the thing that's like the porn
parody
of iron man
we also got folks who send in things
that are supposed to be meant for kids
this stuff is supposed to be enjoyed by
children but when you look at them you
realize they're inappropriate toys
[Music]
[Applause]
this first one comes from angie in
chillicothe illinois
i had to write that up
i noticed you had phonetic uh genetic
spelling i recently got my one-year-old
a new phonics alphabet toy and there's a
mode where the letters sing the sound
they make oh my god that sounds so fun
do you think it's appropriate for
charlton heston to be teaching children
how to say the letter a
i didn't know what she meant until i saw
the video can we play the video of this
toy josh
you could beat that
ah
you damn dirty ape
a is for ape
they're damned and dirty
ah ah
i should have had that gig i don't know
who got that job but true should have
been me do the rest of the letters as
charlton has
b
you bloody baboons
ah
he always defers back to a he's right
kids are very confused they're like wait
how many letters in the alphabet because
it seems like there's 48 like no he just
does a plus
c
see you later
see
yes
all right uh darren mcgregor from
scotland writes in with school in
scotland what
you know him he's a freaking contributor
to the ralph report so i think people oh
[__] hey man i was just as random for
you to be like a dude from scotland this
motherfucker's like i know him
in burbank unless you're talking about
scotland that's next to burbank uh
darren adds by the way smoke a j for me
kevin while i'm in the hospital because
he's going for a stem cell transplant
because he has some cancer so he's
getting the treatment done so i will uh
happily we'll be thinking of you daddy's
thinking of you man all right uh he
wrote in to say well kids love nature
you know more than anything else
probably they love to interact with
animals
do they yeah petting zoos every [__]
kid i see is like this
but you know what's an animal and
they're like let me look it up
yes and uh this is for kids for them to
set up their own hummingbird feeder in
the backyard so they can see
hummingbirds which are fascinating
creatures yeah i don't know if it's
named properly or not let's take a look
at that
hummer's galore
oh my god that was my mother's porn name
oh stop it
that's how i got into film my mother was
in the business before me
you must be hammers galore
[Laughter]
sounds like a bond girl now that they're
done with daniel craig they can go back
to a lighter bomb that's right hummer's
galore could be it so nice to meet
you hammers galore
let's see if you can live up to your
name
these are my bagpipes
this [__] six dicks
bagpipe
take two
and uh this comes from matt vernier he
wrote this one nothing more wholesome
than taking the kids out to get some ice
cream this is the outside of holy cows
ice cream parlor i believe this is in
iowa if i'm not mistaken this is the
display you see outside the ice cream
parlor there at holy cows
if you can see that holy [__]
yeah
i don't know if the kids need to see
this when they're going to get some ice
cream can we zoom in a little bit on the
yeah i don't know
what the [__]
is that meant to be udders or meant to
be dick and balls that's a ball that's a
ball
holding up a cow i mean [__] props
for accuracy man
you know they're always neutering
[__] bulls and when they show them in
pictures and [__] because people are
offended these cats are like let's go
all in on the dick yeah that's the best
part he's standing up how could you not
see it sculptor's like are you sure you
want to include a 9-foot dick it's like
hell you'd like that the dumbest
question i ever heard
son i was born certain of one thing in
this life the whole reason i started
this ice cream parlor i'm gonna build me
a cow sculpture with a realistic [__]
i had a vision okay let me tell you a
little something
i used to work in financials okay i used
to run a hedge fund
and it came to me in a vision
one day i would run my own ice cream
parlor
the only thing i could see was a giant
bull's [__]
[Laughter]
so you make that statue
that would put me off anything creamy i
think as i went into this
so i went to the loch city dairy
i'll just have some sorbet thank you
it's fine thank you so much
boy we got too many people sorry why
would anyone do that
that is real it's real and it's not like
a bad angle of udders it's like there's
a dick everybody put the picture back up
the bit the the big wide-out one but the
wide-out one the first one
see it's a steer it's got it's got horns
nothing else but a dick
that is so [__] up
i mean what is it like to be a child
growing up in that town you're like you
know what from the day you're born here
they put it right on front street
here's the dick deal with it i'll tell
you the girls grow up disappointed i'll
tell you that much
on prom night there's a lot of unhappy
seniors
that does not look like the one at the
dairy i'm just telling you
i've seen i've seen the dairy one i've
been lied to my whole life
[__] the patriarchy
oh where is that iowa i believe might be
worth visiting
let's do a live show from in front of
the
bull's [__]
and then never mention it the whole time
just have it right here between the two
of us
like a third like a third host
[Laughter]
never address it
people are watching online are like did
they know yeah
is there another angle
shut this up maybe it's udders
utters you with the udders
oh boy all right now let's get grim
we say goodbye to folks in show business
in this segment way too many lately let
me wipe away my laughter tears yeah get
ready for the emotional tears real tears
yeah it's a segment where we take
those tears are real okay
that's how funny you were oh thank you
you made a grown man cry thank you so
much won't be the last time that happens
uh we say goodbye to folks who have
entertained us for years but it's just
we've been too many lately we've lost
too many people in the business but we
do give them a send-off for the segment
we call the tinseltown stiffs and now
another edition
[Music]
of they will be missed and these are
just the recent ones uh meatloaf passed
away at the age of 74.
he uh died of covid sadly enough is that
right yeah
and he uh just shortly before his death
went on the record for being a very uh
vociferous anti uh max and mandate
person so i remember he was uh
you know very a little trumpy back in
the day yeah the last time i heard about
him was people were mad at him because
he was trumpy they got to be very
friendly when he was on celebrity
apprentice apparently and that was part
of it
but he also was very upset with being
asked to wear a mask he was one of his
last interviews he said we're being
controlled by everyone but not me if i
die i die but i'm not going to be
controlled he said about being told to
wear a mask so
um
there you go yeah but can't deny his
music he can't deny how great it is i've
been listening to two out of three ain't
bad all week since
that's a great [__] song yeah that
album is great but that song is like and
this one too
[Music]
wear a mask yeah i guess that was
get a vaccine
it's a lot of things he wouldn't do
apparently that list got longer you
should have reissued that song
most popular things i won't do
a cub bull more and then it's like billy
joel's [__] song where he just lists
everything he won't do these are the
things i won't do
uh louis anderson passed away at the age
of 68. this broke my heart what a bummer
man funny funny man sweet man too i've
told this story a million times but it's
bears repeating he used to work out in
the same boxing gym where i used to
train
and he was always trying to lose weight
and always working on that obviously
that was a big problem in his life but
we were working on you know the heavy
bags that hang from the ceiling that you
punch right you've punched a heavy bag
oh sure yeah seriously yeah what's that
like
it's fun
does it hurt no are you worried yeah
your gloves and your hands are wrapped
up it's fun
our time's up
[Music]
you know what i'll do you talk about
your your hiking and everything yeah
i'll bring over practice pads and some
gloves and we'll we'll do a little uh
spar a little boxing workout would you
can you do it without judging me
because if you're like come on really
really hit me and i [__] like round
house you and it doesn't even move your
palm
are you gonna like s here i don't care
if you say it to me but don't tell
people okay i won't tell people that i
can't fight we'll do it quietly it's a
great workout is it really this hitting
[__] yes how can i so uh i was hitting
heavy bag and he was hitting heavy bag
and he was a very funny guy and he was
always being you know self-effacing
self-deprecating yes so
i was kidding with him and i said
you know louie you're really you know
you're really getting it now you're
really hitting that bag you might want
to consider a career as a boxer and he
said
yeah i always wanted to be a jockey
he was a big big man he was a giant man
could not have been a jockey
i i did honestly did not see the punch
line coming yeah
shows you how good of a community he was
yeah i always wanted to be a jackie he
was uh he when i was uh you know a
younger kevin smith a heavier kevin
smith was happy when he popped up on the
scene because he you know weaponized his
size yeah i took notes from people like
that i was like ooh it works for him
yeah so he's about all reports seemed
like a very nice guy and he had a nice
little comeback a couple of years ago
with the basketball he won
an emmy or something i believe he did
yeah he will be missed big bucket of
wind there man how old was he 60 i wanna
say eight sixty-eight well that's too
soon indeed don wilson
creator of a whole genre of music along
with his band the ventures that he
co-founded has passed away at the age of
88 last surviving founder and guitarist
of that band the ventures were one of
the early bands that created the surf
the surf sound yeah they had a number
two hit here in america with this
instrumental
oh that's enough of that [__] come on i
love surf music no man there's a young
lad in philadelphia i would hear that
and go yeah i'm moving to california
someday that sounds cool daddy-o that's
what did it for you amongst other things
wow
beach boys surf music for me it was the
movie uh valley girl
really yeah they kept showing both sides
right the valley in hollywood and i was
like i'd live in either of those places
yeah and i have lived in both of those
places my dreams came true so yay i win
and i'm still alive
let's wait till next month
not it's not true it's true man and this
may be particularly sad although i don't
care for the peanuts um what the peanuts
just were never funny to me i don't have
to be funny but respect the nuts man
these nuts so the first time you've said
that to a man
uh peter robbins the child actor who
voiced charlie brown back in those early
days making the peanuts cartoons
okay which ones uh
it's a [__] happy christmas charlie
brown whatever the [__] they were okay
look out it's a pumpkin watch it linus
is sucking a blanket or whatever the
[__] it was
i think you uh i would much rather see
your penis specials i avoid the ones i
saw many times avoided all of those but
he was the voice the original voice of
charlie brown has passed away tragically
took his own life sadly at the age of
65. good grief
it is
look
not only is it incredibly on-brand wow
it is you could take that joke out of
context still [__] it works yeah this is
literally about grief yeah it is
wow that's a bummer struggled with uh
bipolar disorder some drug abuse and
addiction actually had some prison time
he had a very difficult life and
apparently he was in rehab and then he
checked himself out and apparently ended
his own life so oh my gosh sad news a
statement came from the charles schultz
estate they said
[Music]
so
oh
just wanted to say goodbye to him
[__] you were going to hell man
what else is new holy [__] that was
[__] mean
um
that being said suicide is no laughing
matter and there's some hotline
somewhere calling
nice almost tried
don't have the proper information
if you're really struggling look it up
yourself just
please if you're if you're crippled by
depression
do some extra work
because we can't be bothered to
[Laughter]
there's a reason to live look something
up you got a job go
oh boy
there are things that happen in movies
and tv shows all the time that are just
just wrong just mistakes just bad
bloopers gaffs goofs blunders they
should take them out but they don't they
don't care about the audience they just
let them go right on through we call
these things [__] that should not be and
now for [__] we should not see
here's some [__] that should not be
this one comes from adam schaff he
writes with scream
no
you're lost yeah
doubt it
uh with the new screen movie coming out
i was catching up on all the previous
four flicks there's something in scream
too that i believe is [__] that should
not be
this i love this stuff that this is one
of those scenes i love over zealous
extras people in the background who are
just trying to make the most of their
time yes like [__] louie exactly
in this scene from scream two if you
look at the far right of your screen and
we'll zoom in on it there's a moment
where uh
uh the girl from friends what's her name
courtney cox gets slapped by the girl
from party of five what's her name uh
nevi campbell nev campbell okay
and uh this guy
what nev yeah i believe it's nev
[__] 25 years i've been saying nevi
she lived down the block for me she was
at my house once i called her nevy to
her face oh no but she canadian so she
said nothing see it's nice
that's weird i'm [__] my god maybe
that's why she never came back to our
house i was like so nevvy i said it like
five times you think she'd say something
you'd think yeah she did not to you
she said a lot to other people
i wish she was silent in real life yeah
really
so then i don't i think she's canadian i
don't know i don't know why i'm saying
that i would i didn't know somebody
google that i wasn't gonna source you dr
josh rausch you're not doing anything
he's running the show don't give him a
task fair enough and look up that
suicide hotline too while you're up
there wouldn't you
now i feel bad we should we should
legitimately say what that is yes
people are going to be upset with us if
you don't do that anyway there's an
extra in this more they're going to be
more upset with you why
what is it she is canadian she is
canadian look at that [__] still waiting
on the suicide number thank you so
much
um
so there's an extra in this scene far
right look at the far right of the
screen now here's the thing about extras
and if you've ever
worked on a set you know this they're
not allowed to talk they can't say
anything because if they have a line
then they have to pay them more and has
to be a union actor in one of these
movies right the [__] that's how movies
are made
i'm describing to everyone yeah
you're right i'm not the only one here
um
glad you recognized that
so this guy found a way around it if you
mow the line
it's not technically saying a line he's
figured out he's cracked the code this
guy that's why i love him and he's not
doing peas and carrots no he's mouthing
something you'll see it you'll see what
he's mouthing when you watch this his
reaction to the slap in the face that
nevi campbell gives old
oh i know i love her work
watch him carefully in this scene of
[__] that should not be
i'll share with you
okay okay okay
did you get that all down yes i got that
on film come on sid where are you great
where's she going gail sydney damn
you got to catch that guy on the far
right
wait a minute it's coming wait for it
damn
that's my guy right there
here comes
not the cop
damn
he's the best he's my man i love that
guy literally photo bombing the guy
i had a line and scream too what'd you
say damn
and sometimes bad acting in a movie can
be so bad it goes all the way around to
becoming exquisite acting
[Music]
welcome to the world of exquisite acting
with ralph garman and kevin smith
um this exquisite acting comes from the
1973 brian de palma film sisters oh [__]
i haven't seen that in a long long way
yeah this comes from brian cashion who
sent this margo kidder right um
sure
josh look that up see if marco kinder
sisters
um and at this time of us all being very
careful about germs and getting diseases
and things like that i think this rings
true even more than it did in 1973
however this actress's delivery is
exquisite here's the scene from sisters
did you know that the germs can come
through the wires
i never call and i never answer
that's a good way to get sick
very very sick
that's how i got so sick someone called
me on the telephone
jesus
oh my god
give her an oscar that's a man what a
choice
that's a [__] louie take notes that's
a choice that's exquisite right there oh
my god that was wonderful don't answer
the phone then
all right time to take a look at all the
entertainment news in a segment we call
the headlines
[Music]
well netflix is making a live action
masters of the universe movie
oh [__]
i knew this you should do one of those
universe things no um
i
i've you know
i made a cartoon and everybody loved it
yes they did
universally
they found their he-man who is it an
actor named kyle allen is his name he's
from west side story apparently let's
take a look he must be jacked right uh
no he's pretty scary actually is that
right he's handsome though so he can fix
the rest
he should like to fist him yeah
yes oh my god well done yeah he said
he's dreamy so he'll play
adam it says here in the description i
don't know whether they're gonna do
something else for he-man or not but i
assume he'll be the same dude okay
did they give a synopsis or anything
they do which i think is kind of odd he
plays an orphan named adam who discovers
he is a prince destined to be a savior
of a far-away land he must quickly learn
of his power and the importance of
saving his true home from an evil force
who do you think the evil force is hmm
let me think
um so wait in this iteration prince adam
is uh not not a prince at least where he
is he just he's he doesn't it starts on
earth separated at birth i guess
it smells like somebody's like well the
audience needs a way in these characters
are weird one guy has a skull face so we
should start on earth and like he's at a
starbucks yeah
yeah
like it's he-man latte for he-man
they put it out that's how he finds out
who he really is he's like thank you
grabs a cup he's like oh man
i have the latte
[Laughter]
peter dinklage is upset at disney for
their new live-action version of snow
white and the seven dwarves me too it's
a [__] cartoon classic don't remake
it yeah
is that the same reason we're mad no
it's not the same reason no but we'd be
on the same page people from peter
dinklage is a little person and he's
upset about the fact that they will be
featuring once again seven dwarfs as are
in the title
uh he said they're very proud of
themselves casting a latina actress as
snow white you're progressive in one way
and you're still making that [__]
backwards story about seven dwarfs
living in a cave together what the [__]
are you doing man
he said
the [__] he's very upset about it right
on front street yes however other
dwarves are saying
i need a job shut up oh is that right
yeah there's some in the little person
community who are like you know what
seven of us are going to be in prominent
roles in a major motion picture so
shut up game of thrones not everybody
has your money basically is what they're
saying oh man he got shouted down by
some
um i've shot it way down
oh you're right he's tall my problem i
mean it's
huge
yeah you're absolutely
right it's not little
[__] people man
hey tiger king's not getting out of jail
anytime soon the [__] yeah i was really
counting on that
he has to be released early because he
is getting treatment for cancer and so a
judge took a look at his sentence of 22
years and said okay we'll get we'll make
it 21 years
so they took a year off oh what a dick
move yeah
holy [__] you get the new the good news
is he took time off he did yeah how much
like bad news is one year one year oof
uh reality people are awful
in these shows uh this woman alina kosov
nick novo
i'm sure that's right
and that person is famous for yes well
she's on a tlc show called 90 day fiance
you know if you're familiar with this
show or not
where they like we introduce people and
tell them and in 90 days you have to
decide whether you're going to get
married or not
does it ever work does anybody ever get
married did for these people this
russian bride-to-be again alina kozev
nikova i believe is her name she and her
future husband caleb greenwood who's an
american they are standing side by side
even though she got fired for being
horribly racist
she posted something recently that
dropped the n word eight times talking
about a party she'd been invited to and
also talked about hugh grant how much
she lusted after him but not so much
because his wife is asian so his kids
would be kind of asian she wrote
tlc has parted ways with her she'll no
longer be on their network
caleb is no box of chocolates either by
the way
[Laughter]
he is uh
he is
a tarot card reader that's what he does
professionally
really yes you must be very good at it
he must be very good
uh
my biggest problem with kayla as i watch
their life story is that he insists on
trying to wink when he obviously can't
wink
i hate that
you want to take a look at kayla what is
a non-wink tank take a look at caleb
working out here
the hermit represents sort of that
individual life it could be seen as that
i'm going to give up my my bachelor life
now that would be a big change for me
when it comes to dating i guess i get
around a lot
i mean i feel like i can get sex
anywhere
i love women and i love to have a little
fun
you know what i mean
i love women and i love to have a little
fun you know what i mean
fun
you know what i mean don't [__] wink
if you can't wink don't do that all he
did was lean he just moved his head
that's not a wink
look at pete davidson looking
[__]
he probably gets a lot of girls too
easy kanye
some people are suing universal
studios
very upset why because they rented a
movie called yesterday
uh uh-huh about the guy who wakes up and
only he remembers the beast
apparently in the trailer for that movie
appears an actress named anna de armas
are you familiar with honorable she was
in knives out she was in most recently
in bonds uh no no time to die and she
was in that movie what is it eli
knock knock did you [__] ever watch
knock knock i have looked at you yeah no
reeves two girls show up free pizza yeah
oh my god what a [__] killer flick
yes she's using that too yes she dated
ben affleck for a minute yes she did yes
uh
the two men are suing universal because
they saw the trailer in which she is in
it but she is not apparently in the film
oh seriously yes so is she ever in it
and they just cut her apparently if she
was and they had to cut her out because
she became a love interest for the hero
and audiences didn't like that because
they liked lily james who played the
good girl that he ultimately falls in
love with so they reduced her role to
just one brief scene apparently and they
said she appeared to be in it and so
that's why we rented it and she's not in
it so we're suing you in a class action
lawsuit of they paid 399 to rent the
movie on amazon prime class action
lawsuit of 5 million
holy [__] yes
i hope this works because i'll be next
in line man
i paid to see jaws the revenge
back in june
1988 i believe here's honor here's a
picture of anna by the way if you're not
familiar with her that's her there
look how she's so good in that knock
knock movie she's great she's a great
actress she's very talented really great
but how badly do you want to jerk off to
yesterday the movie in order to sue
afterwards when you realize that she's
not in it after you've paid 3.99
i hadn't even thought of that angle man
that must be the only reason they're
upset that's true
i'm looking forward to this i don't know
what it is but i'm looking forward to it
arnold schwarzenegger you know he's very
uh very much
active on social media you know kevin
smith but still he's active on social
media he is he's bigger than kevin smith
he put out this uh photo this week
that's everybody excited it looks like
something he's going to be starring in
zeus
it says coming february 2022
oh my god no one knows what it is
be [__] that
it's got wait did that super bowl happen
yet see no it didn't that's what people
are thinking yeah because it doesn't
there's nothing on his imdb that says
he's working on a movie called zeus so
they think it's a tease for a spot
perhaps for the super bowl well if they
if it turns out to be a super bowl tease
i am going to file a class action
lawsuit
on behalf of all of us who want to see
arnold play zeus in a marvel type movie
yes because you too wanted to masturbate
while watching yeah
he's my anna de armas that's right
yeah a lot of people want to you know
touch the penises while they watch me be
so s
that's absolutely right i'll testify on
your behalf
i'm zeus i put lightning in your face
i guess he did what he did yeah yeah one
of many things
he also came down in a golden shower and
[__] people
what now it's true really yeah yeah yeah
same thing i did with my maid golden
showers
and then uh you know the baby came
black team and ashley
because one thing we know for sure that
we learned tonight
tim fox ashley well done kids well done
louie
keep working on it
we check in with uh justin bieber every
week by the way
[Music]
that's right
okay be careful i always do this for the
you're a little [__] part yeah but i put
up a picture of me on instagram when i
did like walk 19 and i would just i've
just varied up or proved that it was not
the same [__] day that i took another
picture
i went like this and i was like looking
through this and somebody was like
[__] what are you like racist and i
was like what does that mean and then
somebody explained that i guess somebody
somebody took the okay sign some [__]
hate monger i think it's if it's this
way i think you have to literally twist
your hand like this i believe i hope so
because it would make it very easy to
identify racist and [__]
so can you i don't think you can do it
all night you can't do it it [__]
sucks man because i used to like that
remember [__] okay remember eddie
murphy yeah beverly hills cop yeah i
mean he wasn't the only one but we all
used to go like there were other people
who did the casting people would be like
yeah sure yeah yeah yeah [__] racist
ruin everything i know
yeah that's the biggest problem with
racist is you can't do the okay sign
anymore you're right kevin you really
got your finger on the pulse biggest
problem it's one of the side problems
hey josh we ever get that suicide
hotline
and we've saved them we'll keep working
on that
uh bieber really pulled one over on the
paparazzi this week he really fooled him
i gotta tell you he uh went into church
but you couldn't tell it was justin
bieber because he was wearing this kids
yeah see
you wouldn't know and this he fooled the
paparazzi wearing that as he walked into
church with
justin bieber's wife who's not wearing a
mask at all so clever [__] that he is
really fooled people wait a minute
there's a guy walking in with justin
bieber's wife but that can't be just a
bieber because he's wearing a [__]
ski mask
the government told me to wear a mask
got time for some geek news [__] yeah
all right let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
i thought this was sweet peter mayhew's
widow mangy mayhew
went online and posted a welcome to
carrie jones carrie jones is the actor
who plays black kerr santan uh in uh in
the book of boba fett yes he's the
newest wookie on the block
so she tweeted out you have some giant
shoes to fill but welcome to the wookie
family peter would have loved seeing a
wookie truly unleashed she wrote on wow
that's [__] that was very sweet yes
so we got to make a great [__]
message yeah are you enjoying the book
of boba fett i am i'm drawing the hell
out of it i i love some people like it's
too slow and it's not the mandalorian
but i remember like sometimes during the
mandalorian people like it's too slow
people [__] a lot yeah they too i just
said they're watching and going this is
so [__] up it just feels like
like you're watching john favreau and
dave filoni play with action figures
yeah go like oh what if they did this
what if they did this and then they
[__] smash into each other what are
we doing jabba's got cousins and here
they come
yeah
oh my god it's fantastic and i love how
they're expanding
the world like in the last episode of
boba fett there's no big spoilers but
like they just showed up an abattoir a
meat processing plants right which
they've never really like done before
how do people eat on tatooine bang bro i
was sitting there watching the episode
going like this is [__] interesting
yeah [__] i was like i guess they got
meat and [__] of course they'd have meat
and somebody gotta cut the meat and
[__] look at these the food network
should do a special on that
cuisine of tatooine i like i like that i
like how they expand the universe i mean
the stuff with the tuscan raiders was
[__] dope and [__] like they're just
really
they're doing the lord's work when it
comes to star wars like it makes me so
happy makes me feel like a kid again
where i can engage with it where i'm
like
and it's not like i'm [__] on the
prequels or the sequels those were both
like cool for what they were but this
feels like star wars george i talked to
davey klein dave klein was uh the dp of
uh clerks and when i say dp i mean
cinematographer not like dp um
dave shot clerks he shot maura's such
shot chasing amy uh he shot a bunch of
my early movies then later movies like
uh zach and mary read state clerks too
um he would could not shoot clerks three
thank god because leron taught me how to
make [__] hummus man right and now i
can break the shackles with [__] big
hummus man [__] corporate hummus and
[__] uh dave couldn't do it uh for
clerks three well he he razzled with it
he was like oh my god he's going i want
to do it so bad he's going they're
offering me
a book of boba fett and
back-to-back they fell in love with
dave's work oh gosh i don't know
what do i go away just like bro man like
[__] clerks it's clerk's three
you've been here before [__] go to
space like this is what we dreamed about
and [__] so he was uh he was talking to
me on uh fat man beyond and he said that
the uh
how they approach everything on those
star wars shows
is literally comes down to what would
george have done in 1977.
that's what they put it through that
[__] prison now they add you know
they've got the benefit of [__]
technology and stuff right but that's
that's the move and it's not to say like
you know they're like we don't want to
know what george would have done for the
[__] prequels like they honor the
prequels too the recent episode shows
the naboo [__] fighter like
all the toys come out of the box that's
what's thrilling they don't [__] on like
all those [__] prequels i wouldn't be
surprised if jar jar shows up sooner or
later like that
and they find you've gone too far no way
they can reclaim a man turn them into a
butcher misa kills you know
make him a real hard ass and [__]
he could work in an israeli deli on
tatooine
mr mctahini
you sure like a hermes
oh my god man now
when i go buy my tahini next time if the
guy doesn't do that
you'll be disappointed you'd be like are
you familiar with jar jar yeah
before we say goodnight folks we have to
look at one more tonight what do you
mean good night what time is it it's uh
almost 11 30. it is wow [__] that was
fast i know good time flies when you're
having fun i felt like half the show was
just shooting that [__] video tim and
ashley it did to them too by the way
before we say goodnight there's one last
thing we have to look at and that's liam
neeson's [__]
[Music]
uh for those who are new to the show
what happened to her man
the girl that says that
can she ever check back in or anything
remember she like said it i know who she
is she was a girl at a show one night
she's never come back like we use her
voice all the time
shocking that she's like i'm following a
class-action lawsuit
with anna de armas
for those who aren't aware liam neeson
has a uh famously has one of the largest
penises in show business
huge and so we have found out that there
are facts that we didn't know about his
penis every week people send them in to
our email hbo podcast aol.com you can
send us anything by the way
don't laugh all of that sounds so
ancient it's true
hey kids use email at aol.com send us a
stealth address stamped envelope too
hbo podcasts today well it's tradition
it's always been and it shall always be
i think in this current day you're
supposed to say like dm me in my
comments or something like that or just
dm just at me bro yeah yeah
tell us in the dms yeah well
email me
about any of the things we do here on
the show but particularly about liam
neeson's [__] so let's take a look at
this week's facts liam neeson's [__] is
so big
[Applause]
kevin smith tried to hike it and only
got halfway up
your hiking is legendary sir
went back to the bottom made hummus
that's not hummus
shut up
like you [__] talked about [__] you
jerk
william nieces [__] is so big
it gets a wordle right the first time
every time
are you doing the wordle i am not oh you
gotta do the wordle so much you dig it
how much time does it take just it's
just like
a minute a day since you can only do it
once a day and it's a minute it depends
on how long it takes you to guess [__]
it could be like two lisas
in that one episode of the simpsons
where she couldn't figure out the
[__] jumble and [__] and it might
crash my [__] brain no no it's funny
a lot of important things to do man yeah
you do yeah
while you're sitting in your shower
smoking your joint you can do wordle
just add it to your list scuba that's
not a word
[__] acronym [__] this game
oh the shower chair
mom was right
i went to i went to graceland with my
mom i don't know if i told you this oh
[__] i thought we were gonna get out of
the show without another graceland story
it's not about elvis although he did
make 31 motion pictures over the course
of two years if he if he had a shower
chair he might not have died on the
toilet good point
my mom uh you know she's elderly she's
75 and stuff yeah so kev we're all very
aware of your elderly mother and
graceland she watches the show so
[__] smart enough all right um
there you go she was like uh i she's
like tiger i
uh you gotta give me a shower chair and
i was like oh okay and i called
downstairs and they were like we don't
have that sort of thing
and so uh is this shower chair you said
no i was like really i was like i'm just
gonna grab a piece of furniture put it
in the [__] shower there's a chair
now it's in the shower it's a shower
chair
my mother wouldn't let me do that
so i went to like cvs down the street
and [__] and i bought a shower chair you
know they've got all the old people
stuff and [__]
in that one section which there's the
old aisle i used to breeze by and now
i'm just like that looks comfortable
those slipping insoles look useful
the velcro sneakers
so uh they had a shower chair and i
bought it 19 bucks dude 19 bucks can't
beat that we were in graceland at the
graceland hotel for two days so yeah
we're packing up and then we gotta drive
to the [__] memphis to fly home and
[__] right and my mother's like well
where's the shower chair you gotta pack
the charger i was like well you can
bring it on the plane she's like hell
yes that was very comfortable i was like
i can get you one at cvs and in [__]
florida when you get home she's like
what a waste and i was like well we can
[__] leave it here because you didn't
have a shower chair and now there could
be a shower chair here this could be the
shower chair and she's like well they
should put my name on it
and i was like the grace smith memorial
[__] graceland
yeah man [__] the bar is low now you
know i wound up in entertainment i'm
like praise me for the stupidest [__]
damn it but she was so she still talks
about that [__] shower chair she
texted me the other day and she was like
remember when you bought me that shower
you sure missed that shower i was like
mar it was 20 bucks man i'm gonna send
her eight shower chairs she's only got
one she's gonna buy you a room of shower
chest yeah she can sit wherever she
wants love me now mama
my god
story of my whole [__] life
that's why i made clerks you can all be
distilled down to that once in that one
sentence love me now mama
liam nee's his [__] is so big
when liam was born the hospital gave him
a girth certificate
that's awesome i love that one that's
cute that's a cute one right there i
can't believe i've never heard that in
my life
nobody's ever said girth certificate to
me 51 [__] years that's low-hanging
fruit man but tasty
because it's ripe
very ripe liam neece's [__] is so big
russia is threatening to invade it
and also sad yes that yes
and lastly liam neeson's [__] is so big
neil young just pulled all of his music
ladies and gentlemen if you had a good
time this evening
thank you so much for joining us we
truly appreciate it ah there would be no
show without the man to my left give it
up for the amazing [__] ralph fogger
garmin ladies and gentlemen
let's hear it from my bestest babble
buddy brother mr kevin smith
and that is hollywood babylon for this
week i'm kevin smith i'm ralph garman
bob with the [__] off good night
hollywood
[Applause]
give it up for ralph carmen kevin smith
[Music]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a 10
year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith